well new york city will soon require
customers to show proof of vaccination
when going to indoor businesses
now it's a major move in an effort to
increase vaccination rates but
what if that were to happen here in las
vegas marco mana joining us now live
with what some local businesses are
saying
orgo
well denise it's important to point out
that there are no vaccine requirements
for customers
right now here in las vegas but if that
were to happen and we had to show these
cards to dine indoors or go to indoor
performances
the businesses we spoke to say that
they'd be prepared
what's most important is safety at the
nevada room customers can grab a bite to
eat and enjoy a musical show the
restaurant performance-based hybrid is
exactly the kind of place that would
require
proof of vaccination if it were located
in the big apple
nevada room president tom michelle tells
me if las vegas went down the same path
as new york city he'd be ready i think
we would adjust to it you know we
adjusted to masks we
adjusted to 50 different covert
protocols that we put in place
michelle is already hearing some people
say they're worried to go to indoor
venues due to the delta variant so to
avoid a worse situation
and to keep business thriving he's all
for a vaccine requirement i would
much rather have that kind of a mandate
than a shutdown again
7th and carson restaurant owner liam
dwyer worries a vaccine mandate will
hurt business
still he says safety comes first i agree
with whatever
we can do to keep our our
our customers and our community safe i
mean it does sound extreme to me today
yes but
six months from now it may seem that it
was it was necessary dwyer also says
he'd rely
on his outdoor seating if a customer
does not have proof of vaccination with
them
and everyone agrees we just have to take
things one step at a time
we just have to keep navigating through
this until we can put this behind us
again there is not a current vaccination
requirement for customers here in las
vegas
the mandate in new york city will be
fully enforced by mid-september
reporting live tonight orco mana 8 news
now